this video is sponsored by squarespace
every time you think you know everything
there is to know about a subject
something comes along and changes the
entire paradigm fitness and muscle is no
different tensegrity is a concept that
completely changes the way we think
about muscle and performance this
changes everything right down to the
fundamentals that you learned in pe
we're going to learn about it now and
it's pretty fascinating
so the concept of tensegrity can be a
little bit tricky to visualize which is
why i've brought this little lego
sculpture which i built with my daughter
and basically this shows us how rather
than being a series of blocks stacked on
top of each other to remain upright it
instead relies on tension coming from
different angles it wants to fall this
way but it also wants to fall this way
at the same time and that's keeping it a
lot so then think of the skeleton as
being this stack of bones on top of each
other held in place by gravity and then
the muscles and the tendons work like
levers and pulleys to move the joints
this is what your pe textbook your
science textbook probably said when
you're at school this is accurate to a
degree but it misses the bigger picture
because in fact your bones are suspended
in position by equal and opposite
tension pulling on it from all different
angles by the muscles and the tendons in
this sense we can describe the muscles
more as james earls says in his book
born to walk as tension tuning systems
tension tuning instruments their job is
to apply tiny adjustments in force to
keep everything exactly where it should
be and this is happening all the time as
you move throughout your day and a good
example of this is the hip adductors the
hip adductors aren't only for bringing
the hips the legs together in fact
that's probably not their primary role
their primary role is to prevent
abduction to prevent the legs moving
apart and they work in equal and
opposite force against the hip abductors
so tensegrity and tension it's not just
about keeping your body together it's
also about communication and sending
signals throughout the body so for
example if you have a taut piece of wire
you can flick one end and the vibration
will travel down to the other end if it
has any slack in it it's not going to
travel in the same way this happens
throughout the body and as we're walking
for example you'll use lots of different
signals that are traveling from your
heels from your tibialis anterior all
the way through to your buttocks and
your lats and this is only possible
thanks to tensegrity
so this is possible because the fascia
which surrounds the muscle connects the
joints encases the organs actually
contains its own mechanoreceptors that
means that it can sense changes in
pressure in length and communicate that
information across the body this then
means that action from one muscle can
actually trigger and cause movement in a
muscle in a disparate part of your body
for example when you're walking as you
strike the ground with your heel you
actually move your hips you have to then
contract your glutes to counteract this
and that's then felt across the fascia
across the back all the way to the lats
and this is how movement in the legs
actually affects movement in your lats
and those signals can travel without
having to go the scenic route via the
spinal column and the brain making them
much much quicker and far quicker to
react and as we walk even within our
feet as i talked about recently when
your heel strikes the ground you
automatically plantar flex your foot
goes towards the ground and then as the
the actual bottom of your foot touches
the ground this triggers the plantar
reflex and causes your toes to grip onto
the floor as you lift your heel you then
dorsiflex and bring your foot back up to
prevent yourself from catching on
anything all this happens unconsciously
thanks to tension and tensegrity
this is all very interesting but does it
actually have any implications for the
way that we train and rehabilitate well
in a word yes for starters this reminds
us of the importance of training the
entire body as a single system we don't
want to extrapolate too far with this
and get carried away but suffice to say
that training purely in isolation
probably isn't a good idea likewise if
we want to address any kind of movement
issues or pain or discomfort we probably
want to look at the body as a whole pain
in one area can affect the body right
across the entire system and finally
when operating and performing surgeries
we need to be mindful of the fascia we
don't want to just cut this away it's
not just an inert stuff far from it it
is the very stuff of our movement and
our sensory perception
certainly we want to maintain variety in
our movement if we're to prevent
stiffness and weakness outside of very
specific movement patterns
and in some cases tensegrity may even
reveal better ways to generate power and
to move efficiently reportedly some
african women are able to carry 20 of
their body weight on their heads without
it harming the efficiency of their
walking once again sea born to walk more
analysis is needed but it seems that
this possibly is thanks to their ability
to effectively translate that additional
downwards force into elastic energy that
they can then return and use
jc santana has said to me many times the
translating force and energy is often
more important than generating it as
when taking a running jump from one foot
to dunk a basketball you don't stop at
any point there's very little counter
movement here instead you just hit the
floor with the ball of your foot and
launch into the air from a sprint
by better understanding common
myofascial linkages and learning to
better maintain the elasticity of the
fascia we might be able to tap into
greater and more efficient performance
there's a lot more to discover here
we're only just beginning but it
certainly makes you think
so thanks a ton for watching this one
guys i hope you found it useful and
interesting i know i find this stuff
fascinating or fascinating as always if
you like this kind of training you can
check out my ebook and training program
super functional training 2.0 which also
comes with over two hours of video
tutorials that program should offer the
kind of versatility and variety that the
body thrives on if you could hit the
like button down below that would help
me out immensely and subscribe if you
want more like this oh and hit the bell
button if you want to be notified of new
videos by the way thank you so much for
watching this one and i'll catch you
next time
bye for now
but just before you go let's take a
moment to talk about today's sponsor
squarespace squarespace is a powerful
online platform that lets you develop
modern attractive and professional
looking websites it lets anyone easily
create their own website with zero
coding necessary a website is an
absolute must if you're starting an
online business if you want to make a
name for yourself online so this way
anyone can get in on the act and there's
tons of features here ensuring that you
can do everything you might possibly
need to you can create gated members
only content for example which lets you
earn revenue from your website there's
member management inbuilt email
communication and audience insights
there's also a fully integrated
commenting system with threaded comments
replies and likes powerful blogging
tools for sharing content categorizing
posts scheduling publishing and more and
social media integration the display
posts from your social profiles directly
on your website and that's not all
there's also powerful e-commerce
capabilities with additional third-party
extensions that provide inventory
management marketing streamlined
bookkeeping sales tax reconciliation and
filing and logistics for shipping
globally so go to squarespace.com for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch bioneer viewers get 10 off the
purchase of their first website or
domain by going to squarespace.com
forward slash bioneer today thanks again
to squarespace for helping me to make
more of the content i love thanks to you
guys for sticking around and of course
bye for now